SIR DERMOT TURING: Good day.
It's not morning.
It's not afternoon it's kind
of lunchtime, so good day.
And if you're Australian,
you'll understand that.
And I'm going to talk about
computers, because that's
what Alan Turing is famous for.
So I'm going to skip the
whole story of his life.
And I just thought we'd
home in on some machines.
And I like this stuff, because
unlike modern computers,
they sort of have moving parts
and they're hot and smelly
and they're actually
fun to have around.
And when they go wrong,
you can pick up a spanner
and try and fix them.
And that's kind of where
Alan Turing was on machines.
You can trace this right back to
his childhood and the carpentry
lessons that he took at a
school called Hazelhurst, where
he and my father were sent.
And the emphasis-- very
interesting for the early part
of the 20th century--
the emphasis
was on practical and being
able to do it yourself,
not depending on other
people to fix stuff for you.
And I think that's
really quite interesting.
So he was completely
terrible in the workshop.
His soldering technique
defied belief.
But nevertheless, it
was sort of somehow
a personal failing
if you couldn't
try and fix it yourself.
So he's an interesting
hands-on kind of guy.
And you can trace throughout
the whole of his career
the importance of moving
from the theoretical
into the practical sphere.
So we can start with the
extremely theoretical,
the whole idea that came
out of this famous paper
on computable numbers
that I'm sure you've all
heard of, this
thing that set out
the blueprint for a
universal computing machine.
But this is all
quite interesting,
because this wasn't
about machinery.
This paper was intended
to be about solving
the fundamental problem in
mathematics, which is about
whether there are
rules underpinning
the whole of mathematics and
in particular the question
whether you could have a sort
of process that would enable you
to tell ab initio whether any
particular mathematical theorem
is provable or not.
And the reason I
put this picture
of this slightly balding
guy on the left hand
side of this slide is
because that's Max Newman.
Max Newman, as you all
know, very important
person in the
development of computers,
but also Alan Turing's mentor
for the whole of his life.
And it was when attending
Max Newman's lectures
on the problem of decidability,
the Entscheidungsproblem,
that Max Newman explains
the problem in terms
of a mechanical process.
Is there a mechanical
process that you
can apply to know whether any
particular theorem is provable
or not?
And so Alan Turing
took away this idea
of a mechanical
process and came up
with his idea of the universal
Turing machine, which
you're all familiar with.
So there's Alan Turing
on the right hand side,
and that's a picture
taken at about the time
he wrote this paper.
That's him in his
hometown of Guilford.
And apparently, he's
walking to the station
to get away from
his ghastly parents
and to go back to Cambridge
to work on his paper.
I mentioned his ghastly parents.
Actually it's kind of unfair to
the parents, who weren't really
that ghastly, but he didn't get
on particularly well with them
and that's probably down
to having been separated
from them in his childhood.
He was getting on much
better with this lady, who
was the mother of his childhood
friend Christopher Morcom.
And there's a lot of
mythology around Alan Turing's
relationship with
Christopher Morcom.
Actually, the real relationship
was with Christopher Morcom's
mother.
And it started after
Christopher had died.
And these two found
complementary relationships
with each other.
Alan Turing found a maternal
figure who was basically
looking for her lost son.
But also, she came from a very
important scientific family.
Her father invented
the light bulb.
And I know I've
offended all of you
here in the audience
who are Americans
who believe the light
bulb was invented
by some guy called Edison.
But if you're British,
you don't believe
[INAUDIBLE] was invented
by Sir Joseph Swan.
So her father was
Sir Joseph Swan.
He invented the light bulb.
And she had-- not only was she
a sculptress and an artist,
but she liked her kids to get
stuck in on scientific stuff.
They had a laboratory at
their place at Bromsgrove
and they did experiments.
And this was very interesting,
because my grandmother
would never have tolerated
that kind of thing going on.
It would have been
messy and smelly.
So Alan fitted in really
well with the Morcom way
of doing things.
And this is interesting because
this is in the mid-1930s.
Chris was long dead and he's
still going and visiting
Mrs. Morcom.
And he's talking to
her about algorithms.
This is the most bizarre thing.
You go and talk to
somebody about algorithms.
If you've ever tried it--
and I'm sure most of you
have-- it kind of doesn't
work as a social gambit.
So he's talking to
her about an algorithm
for playing the game of Go.
And these are the
drawings he had
made for her, to sort of
set out the rules of Go.
He's already starting
to think about how
you'd program that universal
computing machine that he's
trying to explain to her about
the Entscheidungsprogram.
That conversation probably
didn't go too well either.
But she is interested
in the game of Go,
and he's willing to have
a go at trying to set out
the rules for how
you'd program a machine
to do that sort of thing.
This is happening
before World War II,
before anybody's
even thought of how
you might go about
creating, in physical form,
a universal computing machine.
And then he goes
off to Princeton,
and he spends a lot of time
thinking about machinery.
And he goes down
to the machine shop
and he starts making some
sort of mechanical multiplier.
I have no idea how that worked.
There are no drawings that
survive of that thing,
not to my knowledge, anyway.
But he comes back
and when he gets back
to Cambridge in the
late 1930s-- this
is about 1938--
he started to work
on a physical
embodiment of a machine
to try and solve
Riemann's Zeta function.
And this is an analog machine.
It's got tooth to gear wheels.
Each of the gear
wheels has a number
of teeth that is a prime number.
And you put them together
and it will actually
approximates to something
that will solve Riemann's Zeta
function.
And this is very
beautifully drawn
blueprint that's in the library
at King's College, Cambridge.
Alan didn't draw it.
That's not what he was good at.
But it was his
conception for a machine.
And then of course
you know about this.
This is a very famous machine.
You can go and see a replica
of this at Bletchley Park.
This the bomb.
This is the machine
that was designed
to find the settings
of the Enigma machine
that the Germans were using to
encode their secret messages.
So all we're seeing through
Alan Turing is not just theory.
We're seeing physical
embodiments of his ideas.
And this is quite interesting.
This is a digital machine.
It's not a universal machine,
but it's a digital machine.
It gives you yes or no answer.
And the wiring that is used
to-- and the way that you could
reset the wiring around
the back of the machine
in order to try
and solve today's
settings-- very
interesting idea.
So we can see the
evolution of things
from these analog machines,
like the Riemann's Zeta function
machine into something
that's more digital.
OK, this is still
electromechanical.
It's still single purpose.
But it's re-wirable.
It solves a different problem
every day-- interesting.
Then of course, this thing.
Now there's another piece
of mythology around this.
This, as you know, is Colossus.
That's where we are today.
The room-- never mind.
And this is Colossus.
So this is not anything to
do with Enigma-- myth number
one exploded.
It is to do with the
Lorenz teleprinter cipher.
And no, Alan Turing didn't
design this machine.
So myth number two
exploded as well.
Max Newman was in charge of the
team that built the Colossus.
But Alan Turing was a
consultant to the project.
So he knew about
electronic valves.
He knew about the weird
experiments they were doing.
When the machine was
having down time,
the mathematicians were
programming this thing
to do long division.
That's interesting.
That feels more like a
universal computing machine.
It's designed for doing
statistical analysis
on these teleprinter codes.
They're actually using it for
something completely different.
[INAUDIBLE] did his head in
because the mathematicians were
trying to play with
it rather than use it
for what it was meant for.
So after World War
II, Alan Turing
goes off to the National
Physical Laboratory.
And here we have
an overt program
to design a universal
electronic computing machine.
And they got into all
sorts of difficulties,
because as you can imagine,
this is a civil service.
This is the austerity
years after the war.
Resources are very
difficult to get hold of.
And it took forever to build it.
This photograph shows it in
a state of half-built nudity.
And this photograph's
taken in about '56,
'57, roundabout then.
The machine still isn't
built. Alan Turing
is already dead by the time
this photograph was taken.
So you can imagine
how frustrated
he'd got when he finished doing
his design and his programming
manual for this machine.
He'd done all the
work before 1946.
And it's going to take another
10 years before this thing is
actually live.
So he's going
absolutely spare not
being able to use
the machine that he's
designed and can program.
It doesn't exist yet, so he's
looking for somewhere else
to go.
And of course, he's rescued
by our friend Max Newman
and he's taken to
Manchester, where
they have something that was
called a marvel of our time.
And this is it.
Doesn't it look dreadful?
Max Newman had managed
to rescue two leftover
Colossi and a seven-ton
truck full of spare parts
from Bletchely Park.
And there's records in
the National Archives here
that show he's asked
for permission to take
these bits away with
him, because he's
founding the computing
laboratory at Manchester
University.
And that's what they built.
This is the Manchester baby.
It had a memory of 1024 bits.
Wasn't very easy
to design programs
that were run on a very
small memory like that.
Max Newman was extremely
clever, and he came up
with this thing, which
is a problem to find out
about mess and primes.
I won't go into the detail of
it because time doesn't permit.
But The Times got
a hold of this.
And they thought it
was absolutely amazing.
There was this guy who
built this electronic brain.
So you can ses--
it's very faint.
You can see it.
It says, "The Mechanical
Brain" and an answer
to 300-year-old sum.
They'd found this problem
that had been left unsolved
for 300 years.
So of course, it
grabs the headlines.
This is the Dan Dare era.
You've got rockets and
computers and robots
and all that kind of stuff.
So Max Newman
invented this program
that you could actually
solve on the thing.
And then of course, they
phoned up Alan Turing
and Alan Turing goes on
about whether computers
can write sonnets and
all this kind of stuff
and gets into all sorts
of terrible trouble
with journalists.
It sort of got a ticking
off from Max Newman.
There's lots of fun around that.
As you can tell, that computer
really was not very useful.
And it did look rather scrappy.
But it was kind of like
a proof of concept.
And it enable them to
go out to a company
called Ferranti, who made
them a proper computer,
this rather clean-looking young
lady with a very clean-looking
computer.
So this was delivered
to Manchester University
probably about 1949, 1950.
And it looks a bit more
professional, doesn't isn't it.
You can't see the wires.
But the reality is, on the
right hand side of the slide--
and if you look carefully just
above the bit of printout,
you'll see Alan Turing's
handwriting which says,
how did this happen?
These things were fiendishly
difficult to program.
And everything went
horribly, horribly wrong.
But despite the photograph,
I think the reality
is much more challenging.
But you can see what he
was starting to work on.
He wasn't working on
mathematical problems,
particularly.
He was working on
biological ones.
He was maths and the computer
to help him solve new problems
that he was interested in, in
relation to growth and form--
how does a horse embryo
turn from something
that's a tennis ball shape into
something that's a horse shape?
As Alan Turing said, a horse is
not a spherically symmetrical
object.
So he had some
mathematical formulae
that would explain this.
But he needed to prove it.
And so what he did was
he's got the computer
here to print out--
well, actually
he's written it out in longhand.
But it's a contour map.
So each of these two-digit
hexadecimal numbers
is showing you whether it's a
large number or a small number.
And so what he's done is he's
shaded the contour map in three
different shadings
so that you can
see blotches appearing like
you might on a Frisian cow,
for example.
That's what his paper did.
And you can see him here
standing at the console.
He's the guy on
the right standing
at the console of the Ferranti
1 computer in Manchester.
So that's the stuff that he was
working on at the time he died.
We all know the story about
what happened to Alan Turing
at the end of his life.
So I'm not going
to dwell on that.
But I thought you
might like to have
a look at some of
these press cuttings
from the time of his death.
I suspect that the
print's a bit small.
But some of the headlines
are quite-- perhaps
one is not supposed
to find this amusing,
but I just think it's
quite interesting the way
the tabloid press pick up
what Alan Turing was doing.
And so we have,
"Scientist Is Found Dead."
but we also get a thing
that says, "Robot Brain
Man" on one of these things.
And underneath the
photograph there,
you probably can't
read that, but it says,
"Dr. Turing, He Fed The Brain."
I mean, it's just
terrific 1950s stuff.
So anyway, that's enough for me.
I'm happy to stay here.
Do I stay and answer
questions now?
Is that the plan?
Very good.
So I'll take questions
and Christina
will tell me when time's up.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
I have some questions to ask.
I'm sure everyone
else does as well.
So who'd like to start?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any personal memories
of Alan Turing?
SIR DERMOT TURING: I know to
you guys I look 1,000 years old.
I'm sure I'm the
oldest person who's
ever stood behind this lectern.
But no, I'm afraid not.
He died in 1954.
I was born in 1961.
All you guys can do the math.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: How would
you suggest he should
be taught about in schools?
SIR DERMOT TURING: There are as
many answers to that question
as there are people
in the room, but I
think he's a very
inspiring character.
And you can use him as a model
for things like diversity
and sort of social
awareness and those kinds
of things, which is very good.
I also think he's very
inspiring in terms of,
it's OK to be a geek.
And let me say one of the
things I'm very passionate about
is that we shouldn't
dumb stuff that you
get taught in schools down.
You shouldn't make it
too easy for people.
You shouldn't give
people the answers.
The idea that the answer
is in the back of the book
is shocking enough, but the
idea that the answer is actually
printed under the
question is deplorable.
So the only way you
get to be a geek
is actually to find
out for yourself
and actually do the hard
work and teach yourself.
And so I think he's a great
model for that as well.
Sorry, I could go on for
another 45 minutes answering
your questions, so I'm
going to stop there and take
somebody else.
AUDIENCE: Sorry [INAUDIBLE].
Have you seen and do you have
any opinions on "The Imitation
Game"?
SIR DERMOT TURING: I have.
Yes, all right.
Has anybody in this
room-- I'm going
to ask the question
the wrong way around.
Has anyone in this room not
seen "The Imitation Game"?
You're all fired.
Go see "The Imitation Game."
It's a great movie.
Well, get the DVD.
Benedict Cumberbatch
is a brilliant actor.
So you will enjoy it.
It's a great movie.
If you think you're going
to go watch a documentary,
you will be disappointed.
You're not.
You're going to watch a
Hollywood movie and enjoy it.
And so that's the spirit in
which you have to take it.
There is a root of
truth in every scene.
That does not mean
that any scene
is a truthful representation
of what actually happened.
But just enjoy it.
It's a great movie.
And it will tell
you stuff or make
you think about stuff about Alan
Turing or about Bletchley Park
that you hadn't really sort
of thought about before.
So I encourage you
to go and see it.
Enjoy.
AUDIENCE: So basically the
perhaps two most famous things
that [INAUDIBLE] Alan
Turing is the Turing
machine and the Turing test.
And what I always
have trouble with
is somehow finding [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm not sure
if we can believe
that these were two completely
unrelated things that Turing
worked on or if his
ultimate goal was actually
for the Turing machine to be
some predecessor to something
much bigger that would also
include artificial intelligence
[INAUDIBLE] Turing test.
SIR DERMOT TURING: OK,
well, these two concepts
are 13 years apart.
So it's not really
surprising that they are only
loosely linked.
So I don't think
you can sort of ever
imagine Alan Turing went
straight from designing
a very theoretical idea
of the universal machine
and the Entscheidungsproblem
paper to his paper
on the Turing test, the paper
that's published in mind.
So it's not published in a-- it
was published in a psychology
journal.
It was not published in
a mathematical journal.
So his best friend Robin Gandy
said that Alan Turing really
enjoyed writing the paper
about the Turing test,
because this was completely
different from any
of his mathematical papers.
There's no equations
in it, for starters.
And it was all a bit
of a joke, really.
And it all came out of this
whole business, the businessman
writing sonnets
and the robot brain
and all that kind of thing.
There was this
whole debate going
on in the late 1940s about
whether machines could think.
And so that was really
his contribution
to this was to say,
look, actually,
let's get away from this
slightly daft question
about whether
machines could think.
Let's put the problem in
a slightly different way.
Because actually,
it's a question
about whether you think that
you're dealing with a human
being or not.
I think-- this is
very interesting.
Last week, somebody
pointed out to me
that when you go online
and the website you visit
wants to check that
you're not an algorithm,
it wants to check whether a
human being-- and it gives you
a captcha and you have to
just type in whatever the four
letters are that you
see on the screen.
It's the Turing test
the other way around.
It's the computer testing
whether you're a human.
I like that.
AUDIENCE: The name captcha
is an acronym [INAUDIBLE]
Turing test.
SIR DERMOT TURING: OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, I will
ask the final question.
SIR DERMOT TURING: Very good.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think Alan would have hoped
his legacy would have been?
Would it have been the
Enigma or the [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE] later
work on biology?
SIR DERMOT TURING: It's
really difficult to know.
My personal take on it-- and
that's no more valid than
anybody else's-- is that I think
his work at Bletchley Park,
although it was still a secret,
was I think highly valued
by him and also
by his colleagues.
And I think that's probably,
if the word "proud of"
is the right
expression, I suspect
that's what he would
have been proudest of.
And actually, I think there's
a link there to the secrecy
as well.
He wasn't a man who wanted
to be in the spotlight
nor wanted to be famous.
So actually, the secret work was
probably fits the model best.
Because nobody knew about it.
All right, well, thank you
very much, and time for tea.